[Music]
et first on the set of a love connection
at season 2 with post Andy Cohen who is
now also looking for love did I hear you
say today single again for you yes yes I
am single again yeah cuz last year we
were talking about Brazilian Andy
Samberg yes so now we're back on the
market back on the market
wow you don't miss a trick yes if they
were to flip the tables on you and set
you up on dates
what would your criteria be what are you
looking for in a guy someone who's very
independent someone who has their own
thing going on maybe someone who's never
seen the Real Housewives I mean I could
go on no I mean those aren't my own that
yes so yes that's what I'm looking ok
available has a job looks like JFK jr.
kind of guy yes sure like a Jew FK jr.
I'll take it u FK jr. yes would you ever
let them flip the tables and set you up
I don't think I would I don't want to
kiss on camera and I don't think so goes
back to your conversation with Ramona at
that one reunion so how's your love life
who you can have tonight tell me I'll
tell you well no on a reality show with
whoever I'm having sex with that's right
I didn't sign up to be on a reality show